le mec il m'attrape par le bout de la
carte le métro mirow a perdu la vue il y
a dix huit ans à cause d'une
dégénérescence de la rétine
il quitte alors son métier de
kinésithérapeute et décide de se lancer
dans le spectacle pour proposer un
humour pédagogique
j'explique j'explique en fait comment ça
se passe avec un chien et puis après
comment ça se passe avec une canne et
après ça c'est comment ça se passe quand
on est mal voyants mais tout ça en fait
c'est pédagogique instructif je veux
apprendre le but c'est hongrie pas pour
rire mais on rit pour apprendre en fait
je me sers du rire comme moyen
d'apprentissage et moi j'étais persuadé
que c'était moi si vous voulez c'est une
idée carte mais je n'ai pas fait trop
faire depuis 20 ans cette année miro se
produira sur la scène de la royale
factory dans le cadre du festival orphée
festivals européens alliant théâtre et
handicap on peut travailler avec des
personnes handicapées faire un travail
professionnel de qualité et c'est aussi
le but du festival orphée j'ai mis en
adéquation ce qu'elle est elle la rend
souvent dans la défense des causes
perdues
justement avec des gens dont on dit que
la cause est perdue c'est ça aussi la
grande force croix du projet really
seedorf est aussi ses dettes
dans la réalité on fait avec les gens
n'assiste pas les gens ont fait avec eux
michel reynaud directeur artistique du
festival met aussi en scène et comédiens
du théâtre
eurydice un esat basé sur plaisir ils
présenteront une adaptation des
exercices de style de raymond queneau au
théâtre montansier avait impressionné
j'ai beaucoup de trac et j'ai toujours
le trac avant puis là c'est encore plus
impressionnant parce que faire avec la
fal les spectateurs de spectateurs c'est
impressionnant pas déjà là j'ai comme le
disait monde si j'ai besoin de
reconnaissance
c'est important puis ça m'a permis au
début de sortie de l'intimité parce que
j'étais très timide et puis ça va les
prendre confiance en moi aussi et puis
ça m'a permis de l'oci d'être appelés
sur scène ce qui est
la dixième édition du festival orphée
s'ouvrira vendredi 28 septembre pour
s'achever samedi 20 octobre
le programme complet est à retrouver sur
internet